bercy n'a parlé qu'à monsieur jean
claude bouchet merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt
permettez moi d'appeler votre attention
sur l'urgence qu'il ya à répondre à
l'exaspération des agriculteurs et des
éleveurs français en fp nombre d'entre
eux se sont rassemblés aujourd'hui
partout en france et notamment devant
votre ministère afin de vous faire part
de leur colère face aux retards
accumulés de l' agence de services et de
paiement concernant les aides
européennes qui doivent être qu'ils
doivent leur être versée monsieur le
ministre je vous parlerai ici plus
particulièrement des éleveurs demandé
partout dans le vaucluse et plus tard et
plus largement de la région provence
alpes côte d'azur qui subissent les
contraintes de la prédation du loup qui
est qu'ils ont engagé des frais
importants pour se prémunir de ce fléau
très récemment j'ai une nouvelle fois
été alertés par la fédération
départementale ovine de vaucluse sur les
retards de paiement des aides
européennes relevant des buzz eroglu au
titre des années 2015 et 2016 jugés
'sans pour l'année 2015 800 dossiers 800
dossiers sont encore en attente d'être
soldés et pour 2016 aucun dossier aucun
je dis bien dossier n'a été instruits
pour paiement ainsi non content d'être
exposés à des attaques de plus en plus
nombreuses de leurs troupeaux des
éleveurs se trouvent privés des moyens
de s'en défendre et se retrouve face à
des trésorerie d'exploitation exemple
cette situation inacceptable et le fait
de la cohérence
l'inconséquence de cette agence de
services et de placement placés sous
votre tutelle
cela fait des mois et des mois que les
élus locaux régionaux nationaux feront
part de l'incurie de cette agence et de
son dysfonctionnement
cette situation n'a que trop duré elle
est intenable insupportable inadmissible
il est grand temps que sur votre
autorité cette agence fonctionne
normalement pour un règlement rapide des
dossiers de ces éleveurs monsieur le
ministre qu'un fort et doux en sort de
celle que cette situation soit débloquée
merci nationalisant récupération
stéphane le foll ministre de
l'agriculture de l'agroalimentaire et de
la forêt
ce président est monsieur le député vous
avez évoqué plusieurs sujets celui de
votre département en particulier sur la
question de l'agencé des paiements je
veux je voudrais rappeler simplement
monsieur le député que si nous avons des
retards c'est que il ya eu d un
rattrapage à faire sur des aides versées
avant mais j'ai pas dit que c'était de
votre faute j'ai dit simplement que
c'est la réalité et je voudrais vous
admettez al mais vous monsieur jacob je
n'ai pas dit c'était votre faux monsieur
je dis qu'on rattrape
on laisse les gones a été obligé de
refaire tout un tas de photos des tout
le parcellaire français et on a pris du
retard c'est vrai sur la question que
vous évoquez monsieur le député qui
portent en particulier sur les primes
ovine ces primes coupe les aides
couplées qui ont été maintenus je me
rappelle très bien des débats à la au
moment de la réforme de la politique
agricole commune prime couple est con et
emmanuel seront versés fin 2016 en
décembre 2016 ce je n'ai pas dis à
chaque fois monsieur le fur nous faisons
avec la sp face à l'ensemble des
dispositions nouvelles à mettre en
oeuvre plus le retard qu'ils avaient été
pris
guillet à ce qu'on appelle la pure en
européen et c'est vrai j'ai reçu ce
matin les organisations professionnelles
la fnsea les jeunes agriculteurs pour qu
on recale l'ensemble des dispositions
pour pouvoir répondre à une seule
question
la rapidité avec laquelle on doit verser
et les soldes de 2015 ça a été fait pour
près de 99% et 6,4 milliards d'euros
les atr de 2016 pour 6,1 milliards
d'euros et 89 % d'ici à chaîne pour 839
millions d'euros
il nous restera les paiements de 4800
dossier sur la shn d'ici la fin de
l'année
donc monsieur le député soyez convaincus
qu'avec l'ensemble des services et le
ministère et la sp nous faisons tout
pour répondre au besoin primordial des
agriculteurs que les peines soient
baissés